America's flatten the curve the task
force says the worst is behind us as
long as we stay vigilant and we'll be
able to open up slowly and safely in
phases and this week some states started
to dip their toes in the water earlier I
spoke to what s coronavirus response
coordinator dr. deborah birx the vice
president said the other day that
Memorial Day which is basically in a
month we will have turned the corner on
this virus and we'll be in a much much
better place is that your assumption as
well we believe that both the
hospitalizations the ICU knead and
frankly the number of people who have
succumbed to this disease will be
dramatically decreased by the end of May
the cases are a different a different
issue because now as we're expanding
more and more testing and remember our
testing was very much prioritized to
people who really needed it forces in
making - people who were in the hospital
people who were sick frontline
responders and nurses as we expand
testing more and more into the greater
community with much less symptoms
we'll see cases in additional cases but
we believe that those will be
identifying the cases that may have been
and are currently circulating in the
community but maybe in that more
asymptomatic are very mild state that we
really want to understand
so how costly was it that the Chinese
government wasn't open and honest with
us in the very beginning it must have
been what a month two months that we
lost because of the Chinese you know I
think there are legitimate questions
that need to be posed about what did the
epidemic really look like in China I
still can't tell you that I can't tell
you how many people were infected how
many people were asymptomatic I think
all that we've been really told are the
the limited number of cases and the
limited mortality which doesn't match
any other expansive epidemic for the
first time this virus sees a population
so we need to understand where they
genetically unique
or was there a lack of transparency and
reporting very diplomatic answer and I
can read between the lines and I
appreciate your honesty some criticism
from some precincts says that the
president does not listen to science and
was too slow in confronting this virus
do you agree with that or not well I
arrived on the scenes the second of
March and I can tell you throughout
those seven and 1/2 weeks he's every
piece of data that we get to him he
looks at he talks through he asked
questions and he asked questions that
shows that he understands the data we
have to understand health charts are
very much like economic charts and so he
has a strong foundation in data in
general and so being able to explain to
him what's happening in the United
States county-by-county and he really
likes to see the data in a very
disaggregated way he wants to know
what's happening at the county level at
the community level at the state level
and what's happening globally so he's
assured them that we're learning from
others as they move through this and we
get reports daily on how the other
countries are handling opening up then
we're tracking very closely how the
states are doing as they open up their
economies and that's integrating that
data every day for the President and
vice-president because dr. Fauci said
that whenever that you guys have gone to
the president with a serious scientific
recommendation he's absorbed that and
taken action that is absolutely correct
we heard from DHS where the scientists
on Thursday say that sunlight increased
temperature and humidity could have an
effect on killing the virus in the air
on surfaces and the president's
spitballing and he's asking questions
would it be possible to maybe target the
virus through a cure using certain
ingredients or using sunlight you didn't
believe the president was putting
anybody in danger
did you know and he gets new information
he likes to talk that through out loud
and really have that dialogue and so
that's what dialogue he was happy at
having I think he just saw the
information at the time immediately
before the press conference and he was
still digesting that information the
president has always put health and
safety first I think you can see that in
the way that he was supportive slowing
the spread guidelines knew the impact
that that would have on the economy and
knew clearly what impact it would have
on the economy yet he realized that the
health and safety of Americans was his
number one interest and responsibility
and that's what he did first and
continues to do as we begin to open up
you've probably never imagined you'd be
doing this much television you're doing
Network you're doing cable you're doing
print you're basically there every day
during these task force briefings in
front of the press Corp do you believe
the media in this country has been fair
throughout this pandemic well you know
I've been privileged to do media all
over the world people may not have seen
me before because it's been primarily in
South Africa and Asia because I've been
working on vaccines and therapeutics and
pandemics around the globe for a number
of years and I think the media is very
slicey and dicey about how they put
sentences together in order to create
headlines I think you know America we
know from Millennials and other studies
that some people may only read the
headlines and if there's not a graphic
they're not going to look any further
than that and I think we have to be
responsible about our headlines I think
often the reporting may be accurate in
paragraph three four and five but I'm
not sure how many people actually get to
paragraph three four and five and I
think the responsibility that the press
has is to really ensure that the
headlines reflect the science and data
that is in their piece itself dr. Burks
thank you so much for everything you're
doing to keep everybody healthy and
clean and
and we're grateful for your service
thank you thank you for having me